it wasn't so long ago that a guy from
dallas texas called alex stein started
showing up at city council meetings
across texas but politicians never paid
attention to him
he's a citizen but they were not that
interested so he decided on a new
approach alexander adopted the alter ego
prime time number 99 alex stein
he became a lot more volatile
and in the process showed us how
unhinged our own leaders have become
here for example is alex stein at a
recent meeting of the dallas city
council explaining why mandatory
vaccinations
are essential
we gotta mandate vaccines because right
now i am losing housekeepers left and
right because listen every time the
service sends a housekeeper to my house
and they test positive for coronavirus i
can't have them work around my kids i
have two trans kids in my house both on
puberty blockers and you realize they
are vulnerable they're immunocompromised
we need more people vaccinated
they thought that was real probably a
compelling argument actually
then stein went to richardson texas and
tried to convince the city council to
start world war iii watch
i'm a sergeant
in the ukrainian foreign legion and i'm
here today
to recruit some of you to go fight in
the war in world war iii when you join
ukraine's foreign legion
we're gonna train you you don't even
need any training we're gonna teach you
as a matter of fact we'd prefer if you
didn't have training because we want
somebody that's all messed up we want to
teach you your gun skills you are a
coward and i'm a hero
this is a hero
you would never know what it's like paul
to be like this you will never know what
it's like to be president you will never
know and you will never fight and you
will be on the wrong side of history and
all you have to do is sign up on this
forum right now and you can go fight
thank you for your public comments your
time is over
you can watch a lot of those on on
youtube spend an entire afternoon
chuckling and learning
alex stein is the host of the conspiracy
castle with number 99 alex stein we're
happy to have him join us for the first
time tonight alexstein it's great to
meet you how did you start how did you
start doing this
tucker man it's such a pleasure but let
me tell you something because we're
under constant trauma-based mind control
from the media so what i did is i said
i'm not gonna just lay down and let them
control my life so i said i'm gonna go
start talking to these politicians and i
was dead serious at first they
disregarded me when i said i didn't
really think the lockdowns were affected
they didn't pay attention so the crazier
i got i realized that's how you invoke a
response these people are what i call
non-playable characters in the video
game of life they don't want to interact
with us when they get elected they think
all of a sudden we work for them and
that's not the case so what i'm trying
to do is i'm just trying to put a mirror
up to the mainstream media and show what
the narrative is and how idiotic it is
because everything i say is just
regurgitated from brian stelter or don
lemon and some idiot at cnn so it's
really actually pretty easy doing what i
do tucker
well there's a lot to impact but i want
to go back to the first sentence what is
trauma-based mind control
well it's actually it's when you turn on
cnn every single second you're going to
see a death scroll they're going to try
to scare you because that's how they
control you they want to keep us in what
is called fight or flight they want
everybody scared out of their mind so
they can't make a decision they don't
they don't only want us to see one inch
in front of our face so we can't see the
big picture because what happens is we
have what is called the mockingbird
media they admit the cia has uh liaisons
in every single form of our
entertainment from the radio television
news and film so you have a media that
will say hunter biden's laptop is fake
yet they have to come out six months
later and say oh no that's real and
they're going to give us the crack pipe
all day long yet on that same laptop
there's supposedly child pornography on
it and these people don't care look at
contagion brown jackson who's about to
be nominated to the supreme court she's
easy on child pornography do you think
that's an accident tucker none of this
is done on accident it is a purposeful
destabilization of the middle class and
that's what i am i'm a middle class
person trying to save it and i'm not
here to virtue signal i'm just saying
i'm tired of being tinkled on and the
government telling me it's raining well
i agree i agree with that and you don't
need to be a meteorologist to know when
you're being tinkled on i would say
what what's the response
you sort of have as you watch the city
council members a little bit of contempt
because they should know this is uh
they're being played but you also feel a
little sorry for because they're totally
overwhelmed like what do they say to you
well that's the thing is when you go to
these meetings tucker a lot of times
people are nervous at the podium i see
people talking about how child
protective services took their kids or
their neighbor's house caught on fire
and their house got burned up and
nobody's helping them so people are
nervous so what i try to do is i try to
put the heat on them i want to make the
politicians nervous of what i'm going to
do and the reason why is you go out
there and all day long the news is going
to tell us about the border between
ukraine and russia but i'm in dallas
texas and the border between texas and
mexico right now is just being flooded
with sex trafficking uh with the chinese
fentanyl that i've had friends and
family die of so the real war is right
here in america yet that this biden
administration wants to just confuse us
and make us think that it's a valid
excuse to go fight world war iii yet the
military-industrial complex just lost a
20-year war in afghanistan and now they
are chomping at the bit because tucker
the reason is is our country is not
being run by human beings it's being run
by multinational corporations that
actually want to destabilize america and
in order to gain a global control and
that's what's happening you look at
these companies like halliburton you
just look at all these companies that
are destroying america on purpose in my
opinion tucker
so you're not going to be on youtube
long obviously so i would just recognize
[Applause]
yes they are yes yes they are alex stein
so if you want to catch
the art he's already created do so now
thanks for joining us tonight alex good
to see you thank you tucker you're a
hero hey tucker one last thing everybody
says i'm baby tucker so if you're
willing to submit to a dna test and
prove you're not my father i would
appreciate that because we're both good
looking we're both funny we might be
related and you're my hero thank you
tucker again i don't think i'm old
enough but i appreciate the compliment
alextein thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight